E aí
[Música]
a
fazer humor é colocar o dedo na ferida
há muitos anos atrás o Brasil era um
país muito violento
e o Rio de Janeiro a cidade onde o rio
era muito violento Mas isso foi há
muitos anos atrás Vocês nem imaginam de
um facções criminosas seu comando
vermelho amigo dos amigos terceiro
comando que o PC já milícia a mistura
formada por policiais aposentados ou
policiais que estavam afim de folga do
serviço mas isso é muito tempo atrás há
muito tempo atrás tinha também a polícia
que naquele tempo esculachar o cidadão
se você fez esse preto e pobre você tá
ferrado já começava apanhando mas graças
a Deus o nosso senhor Jesus Cristo isso
foi há muito tempo atrás é coisa do
passado Caboclo
e naquele tempo de selvageria e
violência tinha muito
muito tiroteio mesmo era era olha só era
bala bala para tudo quanto é lado e
junto com tiroteio e a bala perdida
não tinha dia eu não tinha a noite que
não tivesse o cidadão vítima de bala
perdida até dormindo na cama o sujeito
morria de bala perdida no inferno e foi
por isso mesmo que o Casseta e Planeta
resolveu fazer um programa inteirinho
fazendo piada com bala perdida mas humor
inteligente é adequado à realidade
brasileira e além do mais nós não eram
os responsáveis pela criminalidade nem
pela violência do país assim como os 99
porcento dos brasileiros eram os vítimas
ou no mínimo corremos o risco de virar
vítimas e de qualquer jeito
bom e humor Bora colocar o dedo na
ferida muito bem terça-feira dia do
programa As dezessete horas temos que
entregar a fita para o departamento de
engenharia a pequenos porque naquele
tempo o programa ia ao ar às 21 horas
ele precisava ser gerado para TV Globo
Belo Horizonte da TV Globo São Paulo mas
por que isso é o seguinte a Globo tinha
uma cópia de toda a programação backup
em menos e outro em São Paulo na hora
que disparava fita no rio as duas cópias
disparavam junto das duas outras
capitais Porque caso a rede que é esse o
qualquer motivo no Rio São Paulo ou
Minas assumiu automaticamente o comando
a programação é que naquele tempo
naquela época podia ter apagão outra
coisa que infelizmente também não existe
mais um menor risco a menor
possibilidade de ocorrer no Brasil são
coisas de antigamente crise
as coisas do passado por isso mais temos
esse deadline das dezessete horas e A
Safira 17 horas entregar o programa
plante a partir daí não podia mexer mais
nada não tinha nem que mexer mais nem na
forma nele conteúdo
que acontece que justamente nesta
terça-feira por volta das 5 horas da
tarde uma criança uma menina de 5 anos
morreu na porta da escola de bala
perdida uma tragédia
imediatamente Todas aquelas piadas
brincadeiras
sacanagens perdendo a graça totalmente
fizemos de tudo de tudo para não colocar
o programa no ar olha mas foi em vão os
compromissos comerciais falaram mais
alto
hoje foi mais um dia em que o morro
colocou o dedo na ferida na ferida
errada na hora errada no lugar errado
e eu nunca me arrependi tanto de ser
humorista
é mas depois passou que acontece a passo
o seu humorista é isso pessoal é viver
na corda bamba no fio da navalha
tentando e testando os limites
que tem um monte de gente querendo ver
você de explicar no arame e não tem que
rede lá embaixo É como eu digo são os
ossos do edifício Houve um tempo em que
a Seleção Brasileira de futebol é a
melhor do mundo
pode acreditar mas isso também foi há
muito tempo atrás a nossa seleção chegou
a ser penta campeão de futebol antes do
7 a 1
Oi e o técnico você não vai acreditar o
técnico era sabe quem era o filho pão o
técnico era o Felipe Depois é eu Casseta
e Planeta cobria todas as copas do mundo
e Ló tanto é que o Bussunda morreu na
Copa da Alemanha em Munique 2006 a
cobertura da copa do mundo era tão
importante que nós fazíamos uma piada
por dia para colocar no meio do Jornal
Nacional que era maior audiência do
Brasil disparado naquele tempo que não
tinha água boa satino de internet não
tinha Netflix a Amazon Além disso
implantes
e da Copa D 1994 nos Estados Unidos o
Brasil iria enfrentar a Nigéria ainda na
fase de classificação então eu tive uma
ideia iremos nos infiltrar executar o
Hélio de la Penha dentro do vestiário da
seleção nigeriana para espionar os
nossos adversários deu certo depois cair
na gargalhada o Brasil inteiro
perguntava como é que a Globo coloca
esses malucos nua
e hoje eu fico me perguntando como as
pessoas reagiriam a piada dessas nos
dias que correm
é a pior coisa do mundo para humorista é
ter que explicar uma piada aliás muito
pior do que isso é você deixar de fazer
uma piada porque você sabe que vai ter
que explicar ela depois
eu acredito que infelizmente
seguimos cancelados na mesma hora como
assistentes Mas naquele tempo não
tínhamos um problema parecido ocorreu de
fato quando lançamos o nosso LP em 1990
que tinha como o nome preto com um
buraco no meio algumas entidades
afrodescendentes queriam nos processar
por racismo aí tivemos que explicar
aliás eu tenho que explicar para os mais
jovens né Muito muito antes do Spotify
antes dos DVD muito antes dos CDs as
músicas de um gravadas nos discos de
vinil um aglomerado sintético que já cor
preta chamava sentir long play LP
é do mesmo jeito que dê jeito que quer
dizer Disc Jockey em llp long-play quer
dizer lp1 e no centro do tal discutir um
pequeno furo que você viu Para encaixar
no tocadisco quero aparelho que servia
para extrair a música Total da DP
quando pensei no título preto com um
buraco no meio Eu apenas imaginei a
situação de uma pessoa entrando numa
loja de discos e pedindo ao vendedor
Moço eu quero aquele disco preto com um
buraco no meio
e chico preto com um buraco no meio e
qualquer um é puro não sei se E desde
quando não sei se é assim mesmo
é mas como amor é colocar o dedo na
ferida
naquela capa sem querer acabei
provocando um debate sobre uma questão
que só hoje no Brasil começamos admitir
é Sim nós somos uma sociedade racista
racista machista homofóbica e
preconceituosa e por isso mesmo não
vamos deixar de fazer piadas com isso o
que fazer humor é colocar o dedo na
ferida
de uma feita eu convidei uma socialite
na época muito famosa a Vera Loyola para
passar um fim de semana comigo numa
aldeia de índios no baixo Xingu
era uma aldeia muito muito isolada muito
remota só dava para chegar de avião
monomotor uma logo que desembarcou todos
os índios Perguntaram para Vera pela sua
cachorrinha a pepezinha
a todos os vídeos conheciam a Vera
Loyola e sua cadelinha pepezinha tinha
uma antena parabólica lá eles ficaram
muito decepcionados porque a Vera não
havia levado a sua cadelinha pezinho
nós passamos os dias bem divertidos e a
dilsinhos vivendo lá o dia a dia deles
aquela Choque Cultural né uma tarde eu
estava sentado conversando com oshawa tu
chão é um Cacique da tribo brasileira e
perguntei para ele como é que é que os
índios dividindo as tarefas da Aldeia
as coisas simples Ele respondeu as
mulheres só me conta da roça cartão
linha para um fogo fazem comida é lingua
a oca tomam conta dos animais domésticos
fazer artesanato cuido das Crianças
cuidam de suas que os seus maridos
preparam as bebidas rituais ensinam as
meninas essas coisas todas e muito mais
e os homens eu quero ti que os homens
fazem Ele respondeu bom nós homens Nós
somos guerreiros nós gastamos e jogamos
bola mas a gente não têm caçado muito
ultimamente não fiz um só que piada
pronta e contada pelo próprio II e logo
um brasileiro indígena que até hoje é
vítima de genocídio dos garimpeiros dos
brilhos dos fazendeiros inescrupulosos e
até do governo e que precisa ser
defendido de todo jeito como é que eu ia
fazer E é claro que eu coloquei a pedra
era muito boa e pior era a mais pura
verdade
por isso mesmo o boi está cancelado por
colocar o Dedo na Ferida por colocar o
dedo na ferida dos nossos preconceitos
das nossas e poucas dias das nossas
vicissitudes das nossas misérias e
porque não dizer das nossas grandezas
dos nossos sentimentos mais profundos e
obscuros que estão na nossa na nossa
frente e a gente se recusa a enxergar
Oi e o lojista vai lá e cutuca sem ser
presunçoso sem achado um da Verdade a
moral da história é que fica a critério
de qualquer um eu sempre digo não Me
sigam porque nem eu mesmo sei para onde
estou indo
e quando o motorista vai lá diz que o
rei está nu ou melhor no caso que o
índio instalou as pessoas depois de rir
porque o riso é um ato reflexo em
controlável é uma coisa lá do nosso
inconsciente
É pô depois de rir é claro Chega de
pensar e refletir sobre assunto que
corre que incomoda todo mundo
incomodar beijo Mas em vez disso
as pessoas preferem mesmo é tacar pedra
humorista é muito mais fácil mais pensar
dá trabalho e não é uma faz das vezes já
Espero plexidade quando traz em como
traz sofrimento é muito mais cômodo as
pessoas se pendurar em na primeira
explicação simplista que passa na frente
e o problema é quando o humorista deixa
de fazer as suas piadas de colocar o
dedo na ferida com medo de ser incômodo
para a sociedade e isso é claro Evita o
pato o que Vejam Só paradigma
radicalizou conflito acentua a
polarização e torna o diálogo uma
impossibilidade
no lado extrema-direita querendo
confundir o Politicamente correto com o
fechamento da Liberdade individual
do outro lado extrema-esquerda que não
aceita nenhum discurso que esteja fora
dos seus planos
e Ambos são autoritários e ambos levam a
descrença na democracia
é só ódio e intolerância no mundo que
foi construído na base da cooperação e
da Solidariedade
E aí ele deixa de ser humorista ele
deixa de ser o artista
ele passa a ser mais um conformista
é isso mostra que o Comediante humorista
precisa antes de mais nada ria de si
mesmo e jamais levaram o mundo a série
aliás eu desconfio muito de que se leva
muito a sério que se leva muito a sério
é porque tem algo a esconder
o humorista não tem posição política
humorista não tem mãe no Exercício da
sua profissão ele não tem nenhum lado
não pode ser vendido e também não pode
ser comprado o seu compromisso é com a
piada é com fazer rir e fazer pensar e
por isso mesmo ele tem que colocar o
dedo na ferida é óbvio que como pessoa
física do exercício da sua cidadania Ele
tem ele tem como obrigação defender as
suas concepções os seus pontos de vista
mas isso não pode jamais ser confundido
com o exercício da profissão ou sua
prática diária profissional e eu já
ponho na direita já foi a esquerda e
agora eu quero apanhar do centro também
e por isso humorista tem que continuar
colocando o dedo na ferida mesmo porque
o dedo é dele a ferida é dele também e
na ferida do próprio humorista é que a
piada dói mais
e antes da internet a gente desconfiava
que existe um muito indecisos quando
as plataformas sociais chegaram a gente
teve certeza a gente só não sabia é que
eram tantos indeciso assim então ativos
Na verdade o imbecil não tem muito o que
fazer além do que
exercia na sua imbecilidade
Ah e assim vai humorista atravessando a
corda bamba da vida de um lado a censura
que vem o aparelho do Estado
e vocês sabe o que a Lei de Segurança
Nacional o entulho autoritário que
herdamos dos tempos da ditadura continua
vigente Por falar nisso os advogados
bolsonaristas entraram contra mim e
baseados da famigerada Lei de Segurança
Nacional segundo o estes advogados de
minhas piadas são um Perigo Para a
segurança do país pode acreditar
e do outro lado tem uma censura difuso
anônimo militante e não menos ilegítimo
e pior sem nenhuma distância de defesa
para o indeciso humorista bom quanto à
repressão o livre pensamento vendo
aparelho de estado o nome de censura
quando vem da sociedade pronome que tem
é bom
colocando mais uma vez o dinheiro da
ferida eu gosto sempre de lembrar
quando a política do cancelamento foi
levado às últimas consequências
em Paris na França contra os meus
colegas do semanário Charlie hebdo
foi em janeiro e 2015
quando dois terroristas radicais
muçulmanos fundamentalistas Entraram na
redação e exercerão a política do
cancelamento nas últimas consequências
me matando 11 humoristas aí eles Eu
dedico essa minha participação
bom e é isso aí fazer um morro é colocar
o dedo na ferida Muito obrigado até a
próxima tchau
E aí